all she on get
C e
different I don't do it like that
anymore this one goes here
I move angle
deflection angle
deviation get done Che
done so I'm not going
here off
your foot
work
and in other
side the H work is very
important down
he
e e
the point of a prep drill is that you
have as much of the form as possible
okay so as I go here I'm going to get
smaller my elbows are going to come in
towards my Center
Line and uh he can't pull them okay I
don't he I'm not going to let him pull
him off the center
line and I'm not going to get
bigger okay everything is going to
compress so he's pushing and everything
compresses okay
tight up around
[Music]
up leave it there
turn not big movements like
this
[Music]
you elbow in
I don't move my
arm that's
it it's up it stays
here I
[Music]
turn
okay e
all
right I
enter so that his elbow goes up do you
see that
timing don't push it
forward as I'm
here I
enter my hands going behind my head his
elbows going
up okay and I
step so that I'm not pulling
him I step where it doesn't change that
relationship if I
turn
here right about here is pulling on
me so I step where it doesn't pull on me
and I turn so it doesn't pull on me
so I had to go back to the single point
pivot don't try to lift it here come
underneath it I'm underneath it boom
turn as I shift onto this foot I'm on
the other side I haven't stretched the
grip at
all pushing it
up
boom I'm on
the grounded foot ready to
enter careful you step over
here it's going to pull you you
see step and turn only part way it's
going to pull
you so you step where you you don't feel
him at
all you
rotate so you don't feel him at
all
okay you don't get to
pick the non contestation is picking for
you okay try it again
so when I move here his arm bends more
okay which means he starts to bend
more okay on that weight Shi that's not
why I do it
but that's a consequence of it so as I
come around when I yield back this way
hand can
lower not pulling it
down but by shoving his
elbow
back in this action here you see that's
what happens when I do the turn the way
I'm saying to do it his elbow continues
to go up
and back over the
top you guys see
that so now his hand therefore is going
down which is why I don't have to pull
his hand down okay so as you make his
elbow go up the more vertical the lower
that hand goes you see okay I don't have
to pull on the finger fingers once I
feel his
resistance I go over the fingers this
way make his elbow up more then it's
easy it makes no sense you're going to
do all this and then you're going to
go you have to go around the energy
Point
who my hand just opens and Spills
nothing in it okay if you're pulling
down on it you're just a
contester not doing the art go so every
time nine out of 10 times you taking
you're going to actually go
forward it's so you can get on the other
side of the resistance so we'll make it
more
obvious okay and when I step forward I
can get on the other side of that do you
see then you add his grip to it and his
grip turns with me I can get now I can
push straight down without the
resistance okay
so when I come over here for example
to lift that you can feel his weight
there so I don't I don't lift the hand
right I've moved myself under it you see
I'm under it then as I pass it it goes
behind my head do you see it's behind my
head then I move out from under
it you already using this principle on
the first one
enter so you can get around the inertia
so enter up pass it it's behind me now
see don't go like
this that's how we used to do it okay
one pushing passing go to the other side
same thing here don't cut down
here you're going to
enter you can come up a little you're
going to enter so I can get on the on
the other side of the finger resistance
so I'm on the other side
this is something
different and this is something
different I'm stepping into the street
spot